good morning I'm currently trying to
pack to head them to Pittsburgh right
now it's also Maddie's birthday so happy
birthday
DJ mini Matt after we go home to
Pittsburgh I'm dropping my dog off and
then heading to Europe so what's gonna
be a really fun trip the first I need
some coffee I need a pack and I'm also
still recovering from e3 so this is
gonna be quite an interesting day anyone
over sir here's the real question how am
I gonna pack for three weeks for Europe
in a carry-on when I can't even pack for
a weekend in Vegas in a carry-on tank
tops seven eight eight all right I'm
gonna continue vlogging on my GoPro cuz
I gotta pack this camera up so we'll see
you on the GoPro
we made it I don't know how over here
ready to board and off to Pittsburgh
Mady is so excited we even a type of
Starbucks not much fun
I made it home last night now we're
gonna go run some errands before we head
off to our big trip Mattie and Bo being
best friend hey Maddie not nice
here's the picture some of you might not
have ever seen or if you haven't seen it
here's a refresher Justine
2002 senior picture the offer is done I
have no idea
I'll try to go get our nails done every
time we go home it's always a struggle
finding the place to go
it is Istanbul so after that we're gonna
be going to celebrate my dad and
Maddie's birthday for dinner but Maddie
can't come to dinner but it's okay
because we got invocate with his name on
it this one is by the outlets oh should
I call them yes call them give him a
call
be a good family go you would have an
appointment in the next like 20 to 30
minutes for two mani-pedi okay we're
here is a new place you've never been
here before
this building is like brand-new I've
never even seen this before they
basically have changed this entire town
since I've been gone there are
disgusting locusts everywhere every 17
years they come out of the ground this
is their year dude there's a great clips
right next door
I need a haircut so bad but I'm so
afraid of just getting a stranger to do
my hair am i doing nice black nail fit
Sam I look really good I love it yeah
where you do it won't get like a dirty
Wow
you always get better manicures than me
every single time we try to go to great
lips I think I'm okay you can try if you
want but well I don't wanna go if you're
not gonna go
you don't trust Great Clips I thought
that I'll trust the knife don't feel
like doing it right now
Oh God but I don't think we get a
haircut for a really long time your hair
looks the same whether you get a haircut
or you don't get a haircut yes good she
basically gave up on my hair because
it's my hair it takes so long to dry and
it's such an ordeal so she's like how
dry do you want it does like this is
it's a you know what don't wanna
think that was definitely the quickest
haircut above a lifetime your hair looks
nice in the back
well I can't see the front I would get
that from my own self you guys hear that
sound they're like locusts cicada they
may be the same thing but my goodness
they've had like a crazy invasion
because every 17 years they come out of
the ground and here they are back here
on cake duty Oh am I gonna be sitting
back here with the baby
I had Brian's birthday we also told him
for his wedding gift that we're gonna
get him rock band so we have to get rock
band then you get a battery and a
computer charger
I forgot what else I need it don't work
by free we need up on rock bands for
Brian even jyothi's like are they
bringing rock really let it go Brian
he was so attic guy like every day he
was like looking for in the mail he's
like really good or we're gonna get it
today for so heavy
here's the card what is that it is so
creepy
No thank you Dad for giving me all my
goodness it's my birthday
Brian's rock band yay we don't want to
bring it in so it's gonna stay in the
car
seven
happy birthday thank you
once you know in shock you didn't know
our family loves cake
hello we have two cakes for four
birthdays Maddie's not here regard for
Debra's where they advise day it's like
Chuck destroy the stock Auto thank you
Maddie got a some birthday cake but
Maddie's not even here to enjoy it the
cake is gone almost we took it to go
what a pretty little view freeze on
family pic Judy I can't believe it we're
leaving tomorrow
we haven't even planned our trip the
middle of the trip we have certain
destinations but then in between all
right let's see end this vlog I gotta go
pack I this is probably definitely not
my best vlog so I'll see you guys later
Xbox 1x and we are going to unbox it and
it doesn't even come out until August